i started a pe firm alone to buy a
business but it wasn't your typical pe
firm my office my quote unquote office
was just a library at school there was
no fund uh like no money i had a lot of
help i had over 50 unpaid interns come
from craigslist and i had them sift
through over 400 000 private companies
for a year and a half before i found
eggcartons.com
[Music]
so a while back maybe a month ago i came
on here and i was like um
dude there's this business have you
heard of this business called
eggcartons.com
and you're like no what is that well
that's exactly what it sounds like you
go to eggcartons.com and it's a place
where you could buy the packaging the
carton for eggs um and like but also
packaging for a bunch of different
varieties of eggs like huge shipments
small ones eco-friendly not eco-friendly
but also just like in general like other
packaging materials as well
so i was like yeah fascinating business
right like you go there it's an old
school looking website you know it's
like dial 1 800 eggs dot com you know
whatever like to call us to place an
order
and i was like this is fascinating so i
dug in i was like who's behind this and
i basically found that it used to be
owned by this guy he ran it for 24 years
i was like okay this sounds about right
you know his linkedin picture was
him like with a you know like a phone
with a cord in it and he's like got it
up to his neck and he's like sitting at
a messy desk and i was like ah this
looks like the guy who started
edcard.com 25 years ago
but now as i notice oh it says like he
ended his ownership one year ago so who
who's behind this and i saw that there
was this woman named sarah moore who was
like not what you would expect to be
like it's like oh this person should be
like the ceo of lululemon or something
like that why is she getting into egg
cartons of all
like beautiful harvard graduates
yeah like you he looks like a celebrity
a little bit um
and so i tried to reach out to her i
couldn't get a hold of her and but i
couldn't resist so i came on the pod and
i told the story it's like yeah so
basically it looks like she purchased
this business uh she did like one tiny
interview about it
and
but i had done one thing that i didn't
tell you about i don't think that day
which is i've been experimenting with a
format that i wish people use more on me
like when people reach out to me they're
like oh i'd love to talk to you sometime
like if you have a question just send me
the question in fact if you have a bunch
of questions like just send me a google
doc i'm going to look at it and if i
want to answer i'll answer if i don't i
don't and so that's what i did to her i
go
i sent her an email i said egg cartons
like with five exclamation points i go
that's hilarious like what a hilarious
niche i go we got this podcast i'd love
to feature you on it um i have five
questions for you on this google doc if
you answer them with bullet points i'll
tell your story on the podcast we get 20
million dollars a year it'll be great
for your business i go this is me on
twitter by the way whatever i sent it
no reply for
20 days
um
then she go she emails me out of the
blue she goes
i couldn't have paid someone to make me
sound as cool as you and sam did on the
podcast last week thank you so much i
filled out your google doc i think
they'll answer your questions i would
have responded earlier if i didn't think
this was spam um blah blah send me send
me your address i'll send you some
world-class egg cards right so i want to
read you what she what what what did you
heard what she replied but did you want
any are you gonna
are you gonna accept those cartons
very nice really yeah very sorry very
nice of you sarah but thank you but no
thank you no dude everything in the
house could turn into like a toy storage
container you they have toys for all
shapes and sizes all right so all right
what did you say so i basically said
here's my question i go you go you
bought eggcards.com did you buy it alone
as part of a pe firm she goes alone-ish
i started a pe firm alone to buy a
business but it wasn't your typical pe
firm my office my quote-unquote office
was just a library at school there was
no fund
like no money i had a lot of help i had
over 50 unpaid interns come from
craigslist and i had them sift through
over 400 000 private companies for a
year and a half before i found
eggcartons.com
what
yeah i know then i go
i so that was my first question second
question i go how the heck did you buy
it uh oh no why the heck did you buy it
what about the business made you want to
buy it was it the name the customer
retention what drove you to it
she goes my goal was to buy a business
with all debt so i could have 100
ownership i had no collateral though
except for my 2012 rav4
so
i was trying to find something that was
already stable enough that i could pitch
a bank that the business itself was the
collateral instead of my rav4
um that so i needed historical cash
flows this business fit because it had
been profitable since it started in 2001
had a high barrier to entry given the
domain name and 100 plus other similar
domain names that they own like egg
cartons like misspelled and carton.com
uh blah blah blah
then she says the founder has usually
purchased all these domains over the
years to protect their like their demote
it was simple enough it was also a
simple enough business that somebody
with zero operational experience me uh
and average intelligence me could
operate if they tried hard enough i was
like wow this is incredible
then
i said i said i live in silicon valley
people here are obsessed with crypto ai
blah blah blah they would underestimate
edcards.com can you give us a sense of
the scale of the business that's a
really good way to find that 10 million
that's a beautiful way to frame that
question
because you nagged her a little bit like
you said something a little rude you're
like yeah you know it's probably not
that big but maybe it is you know like
impress me right i would think this is
small
but you know
i'd love to be surprised would you say
that this is more than this and less
than this and so she anyway she came
back with
i'm in the middle of something that
prevents me from sharing the numbers
publicly uh all i can say is that our
revenue is less than 50 million
and i was like oh okay okay but that you
not less than 20 if it was less than 20
i feel like you would've said less than
20. i feel like that that would be the
case
um i said how did you negotiate the deal
she's like ah there's a bunch of
contacts here she goes in summary i
harass the owner until he replied then
we hit it off we came up with the
valuation together then i contacted over
100 banks most of which told me to f off
one of them threw me a bone and agreed
to an under uncollateralized loan the
final deal was 75 bank debt and 25 the
seller's note she bought this with no
money down
like the bank financing and the seller
financed it
she said before buying the business i
had i i overpaid an accountant to check
my work and do an audit of the business
because frankly i had no idea what i was
doing his fees got rolled into the deal
itself so uh she used an account to
cover her ass but also paid him out of
the deal itself
this one is amazing any other fun
tidbits or anecdotes i i could share
here's what she says this is where it
gets great she goes
uh while searching for the business i
participated in several research studies
just to make money uh like to while i
was doing my search i went from i went
legally blind from a deodorant study for
a bit so i had to take a break from
working from working until i could read
again
she goes my response rate was awful i
started doing borderline insane things
to get a reply at one point i took a
photo of myself wearing a sweatshirt
that said i want to buy your business
with a massive grin and i faxed it out
to thousands of businesses a day
to this day i run into owners who
recognize me from those faxes one of
those owners is actually my neighbor
then she says the library we worked out
of required a school id to enter most of
my interns didn't go to the school so we
had to get fake id's for all the interns
to get into the library
every time we hired someone there was a
lag because we would need to get more
ids
during before covet i used to fly to
china i needed to examine the egg
cartons on my first trip to india i got
held by indian customs and interrogation
for hours because they didn't believe
that i was coming to india alone they
did not believe that i was coming to
investigate egg
cartons uh related to india i almost got
killed there i rejected a shipment from
an indian vendor the his whole family
lived there he was furious started
chasing after me the hotel put me into
incognito mode for my safety my driver
luckily was at the door that i ran out
of otherwise i'd probably still be there
buried underground
um she goes when i bought the business i
considered an egg company but now i
think of it as specialty packaging forty
percent of our business comes from
things
entirely unrelated to eggs you'd be very
surprised by our customer base you know
think big brands like boeing spacex
disney madison square garden crayola et
cetera anything that requires protection
and separation is fair game
um anyways there's one one more i should
say but dude what's the other one
is sarah moore not my hero is she my
hero is she not my hero this woman's
wonderful why is she why didn't she talk
about this publicly more often this is
like it i feel like there was tons and
tons of stories there
dude you know
people there's some people who are so in
the game
that they're like
they're like oh yeah what am i going to
stop and chat about the game like i'm in
the [__] game right like that's the
feeling i get from her i've met some
people that are like this that they're
sort of like it's a combination of
they kind of don't realize how story
worthy their story is until like quite a
bit later and the second thing they're
sort of like you know either they just
prefer privacy or they're like
yeah i don't really know why i need to
do that so why would i do that it's
going to be kind of braggy and kind of
weird and what's the benefit and maybe
i'd just rather be personal um so i
think that like i know a handful of
people that i'm like dude i wish i could
tell their story on the podcast because
they're epic but they just don't see
value in this and they're also not
consumers of it that's the other thing
i've noticed most of those people don't
listen to a bunch of podcasts or take
inspiration from it so it's kind of a
foreign idea to them they're like
they're like people will care it's like
yeah of course people will care about
this this is awesome
so anyways i was totally inspired by the
story and she is uh kind of amazing she
is one of us she no small boy stuff for
sarah moore
so i think she's only when you if you
google her you basically can't find
anything i mean there's next to nothing
on her there's like one or two pictures
there's very little i found one article
where it says that she's 28 and she uh
it says she answered the question what
inspired you to start buying companies
she says freedom what is your mantra
don't take counsel from your fears like
that's pretty much all she and like she
answered nothing this woman's amazing
why can't we find anything about her
there's a lot there's a lot going on
with her we need to uh
convince her to come on there's a 30
chance she's a fat guy named craig so
like you know we could be getting
catfished here i wouldn't put it past
her uh but
i'm gonna go with the with what i see i
think she's amazing
[Music]
you